[Music]
what you think he can't get any worse
for quid-pro-quo Joe he decided to come
out of hiding this week it was an
unmitigated disaster
small sample excuse me you know you're
supposed to coffin to your elbow I don't
know sir I learned that actually
covering your white house you know
actually actually that's true but
fortunately I'm alone in my home but
that's okay we have to take care of the
cure that will make the problem worse no
matter what why doesn't he just act like
a president that's a stupid way to say
sorry go ahead no no I probably best I
don't I just can't figure the guy it's
like this I don't know it's like
watching a yo-yo I shouldn't have said
it that way it's like watch it that way
our secretary stayed insisted and this
broke the meeting up basically in terms
of influence that this be called the
Luhan virus oh boy good news for Biden
maybe no one paid attention viewership
for his virtual happy hour this week
2,800 viewers and just breaking tonight
Biden caught in another lie because it
turns out Biden Obama sought millions in
CDC funding cuts completely undercutting
Biden smears and lies against President
Trump which are saving thousands of
lives of course now Biden was asked
about this moments ago he didn't have a
good answer take a look should the Obama
administration have done more to
replenish the supplies in preparation
for future outbreaks well we we spent a
lot of time I was not part of it our
administration spent a lot of time
working with the incoming Trump
administration laying out exactly what
could happen with the future pandemic oh
boy reaction foxnews contributors tammy
bruce jason Chaffetz Tammy sixty point
eight million Americans got that virus
hundreds of thousands hospital
by the time Obama and Biden themselves
declared a national emergency thousand
that Americans lost 13,000 Americans in
a year and tens of thousands had
contracted it in the media we didn't
have the death count we didn't have the
contracting counts then why is it
different now that was a pandemic this
is a pandemic it sure is and obviously
there's bias there was protection then I
think what Joe Biden is experiencing now
which is a little surprising even in
that first debate when Kamala Harris
went after him was the fact now that
questions are being asked and mainly
because some of the media they have a
candidate they prefer other than Joe
Biden
well what's fascinating too and why his
week was so bad he was trying to hide is
that there really is no competition for
Donald Trump and the other problem the
Democrats have is they have spent over
three years lying to the American people
about the capabilities of Donald Trump
and now that he has daily unfettered
unfiltered ability speaking to the
American people dealing with a major
crisis for all of us they're finding out
how much they've been lied to that's why
his numbers have gone up so considerably
and then of course you've got the issue
with with Joe Biden is that there is
there's never really been any real
leadership the Democratic Party knows it
they they and then they complain that
you know they're getting blown out by
Donald Trump but the fact of the matter
is look I've opted to remain in
Manhattan we are reaching the world here
through modern new technology foot Park
for me from my apartment Joe Biden has
every capability of reaching people if
they were interested and the Democrats
have to worry about a lack of enthusiasm
which is what we've seen well obviously
the the poor numbers he's been
experiencing online again it he got he
got it wrong again we hold these truths
to be self-evident etc etc endowed by
their creator that no one doubt by the
thing the thing all right Jason
I don't care put whatever term you want
it this guy is lost in space and it's a
little scary every day that he wakes up
and they turn on the cameras is a bad
day for Joe Biden
person was elected to the United States
Senate in 1972 I was barely starting to
play soccer then he's all about
yesterday he has no vision for the
future and I got a beef with you Sean
Hannity because I had to watch part of
that Town Hall to come in here and talk
about it and they tell you it's an
embarrassment because he likes to do
numbers well there's two things here and
then he starts Eddie loses count and
then he has to go back to number one one
question I had he went to number one
three times it's just I love the existed
my favorite moment though this is my
favorite moment he's doing the town hall
thing and then all of a sudden he
forgets he's on camera and it's just
like starts talking walks off care I
mean this is not Tammy this is serious
now this is a president United States
you need strength stamina mental
alertness you need to be sharp and this
is important because the Democrats it is
very hard to believe and look the 20/20
campaign is essentially been put on hold
right but in the traditional way the
traditional rallies for Donald Trump
have been put on hold but the Democrats
I think still are looking for a way to
get out of this and it doesn't mean they
have to even have a brokered convention
in a classic sense someone could step up
close to whenever they have their
convention if they're still able to do
it and say look he's got we agree he's
got to go
his family wants and and watch out watch
out for someone like Cuomo who thinks
that he's the one who can beat Donald
Trump watch out for that yeah the guy
that did no preparation for any
emergency all right thank you both